I was most interested in self hypnosis
to actually really just to help me get
to sleep so over the years I practiced
it with friends on hypnotizing others
and I mean really just for curiosity to
see what it could do and how real it was
and was just it was clearly very real
and there on myself is kind of like
experimenting on myself on my own mind
and guiding your own thought patterns
and identifying what little tricks work
with your own mind and eventually found
a couple tricks that are incredibly
effective for the question that I
started with which is how do you go to
sleep quickly so there is the the short
and easy which works maybe 60 70 percent
of the time and there's the sort of
guaranteed home run sort of the the big
guns takes a little bit longer but it
works essentially a hundred percent of
the time so the short and easy is I've
actually shown it told a couple of
people this trick and it's helped them a
lot and it's kind of like a for those
people who have a lot of racing thoughts
it's almost like a jiu-jitsu mover I
studied a lot of Aikido so it's like
keto as you use your opponent's energy
to achieve what you want so what you do
is you close your eyes and whatever
comes whatever visuals you see you start
to really get curious about them you
might it doesn't matter what pattern you
see you might see some you might see it
the vague images of a chair and you say
well what does that chair look like
what's its texture is it moving is it
floating is it spinning around is there
something on it and because your mind is
racing that object whatever that object
is it might be a chandelier it might be
just weird images they'll start to
change in your mind and you just get
curious what's it going to change into
next and the reason that sort of like a
jujitsu or I couldn't move is all those
racing thoughts all those firing neurons
get redirected to that object because it
gets curious like really what's the kind
of change that's so wacky like what is
it going to change
- and then the object starts to take go
from this like amorphis thing that's
very far away
- coming clearer and clearer and closer
to your mind and sharp and sharp and the
sharper and sharper becomes in focus the
more you're getting deep in trance the
more you're letting the waking world go
by and you just keep asking well what's
it gonna change into next I have no idea
let's follow it so that works a good
fraction of the time and it just calms
you it just takes all those racing
thoughts and redirects them to that one
object and if you find yourself straight
you're balanced just redirect away
where's that object what's it gonna do
next let's get really curious and
there's so many things to have what
colors are it is it sparkling what's its
texture is it gonna morph into something
oh my god there's my father or there's
you know and just watch it and the more
you watch it the more it crystallizes
the more you're going deep into trance
and you leave the waking world behind if
you are I'm a little more visual if you
have you're more auditory and you tend
to hear kind of a dialogue in the back
of your head
there's trick number two this is a
little bit of a weird I actually haven't
told anybody this trick again I'm so
glad it's just between you and me I
asked the audio generator in my brain
which is you know whatever audio
engineer is popping forth that little
audio in our dialogue to focus on
generating a random double-digit number
between one and a hundred
so why double digit well single digit is
not a really difficult enough task one
three four it doesn't really engage your
auditory engineer very inner auditory
engineer and double digit is just comp
you know just enough of a effort the
your audio engineer can't play some
irritate and keep you awake dialogue and
do that other task it has to pick one or
the other and why random well if you
just do 23 24 25 sequence it's kind of
boring and then your audio engineer can
go back to that really irritating voice
that was keeping you awake so by asking
your audio engineer to do this task of
generator random double
digit number and then to keep the audio
in the video engineers in your head that
are generating this noise busy you
assign them the task of seeing those
numbers so I kind of imagine like a
cannon launching these numbers in the
sky and watching 2270 657 feel like
people listen here I don't think I'm
crazy but this X it really works it's
like all those sort of inner racing
thoughts you just take them away from
their tasks that they were doing which
was keeping you up and you focus them on
tasks that you would rather have them
doing tasks that are actually helping
you get to sleep faster
you